Speaker 1: You know, we spoke last week about
how many companies that were celebrating Pride
Month have a long history of donating to homophobic
politicians.
I want to now follow up on a story that we
talked about some time ago, several months
ago.
The company Boeing has quietly resumed donating
to the Republican traders that some know as
the Sedition Caucus.
This is a Daily Beast article which outlines
what's going on really well.
Let's take a look at it.
And it says, After briefly swearing off political
donations in the wake of the Capitol riot,
Boeing is now throwing cash at officials who
fought to overturn the results of the 2020
election.
In a recent filing with the Federal Election
Commission, Boeing's political action committee
reported major contributions to three Republican
members of Congress who voted to challenge
the results of the Electoral College.
Steve Scalise, disgusting guy, and then the
lesser known Vicky Hartzler and Jack Burgmann.
The report being boings first to show political
contributions after the assault on the Capitol,
also disclosed a twenty five thousand dollar
gift to the Republican Attorneys General Association,
whose fundraising armed arm helped promote
the January six rally to, quote, stop the
steel.
Boeing contributed less than half that amount
to the organization's Democratic counterpart.
Boeing gave Scarless and Hartzler each five
thousand dollars the limit for an election.
Burgman, a Michigan conservative who in December
pushed erroneous claims of election fraud
in his home state, got half of that amount
Boeing previously donated to all three.
Now, the article does go on to say Boeing
also gave money to Democratic officials like
Nancy Pelosi, as well as Republicans who did
vote to certify the election results.
The aerospace and defense giant also gave
the maximum one hundred and five thousand
dollars to both parties, House and Senate
campaign committees.
This is what people really have to understand
about this.
First of all, the headline is Boeing quietly
resumes donating to Republican, you know,
to the Sedition Caucus.
I call them the Republican traitors.
It may be worse than that because Boeing may
never really have stopped the donations to
these people.
And what I mean by that is when the January
6th riots happened in early twenty twenty
one, obviously twenty twenty was over.
So twenty twenty contributions were done.
The twenty twenty election was over and the
twenty, twenty calendar year was also over.
Now it's twenty twenty one and they are again
making contributions, so even to say that
they stopped them between January and June
when donations are really only now ramping
up and they've hit their maximums anyway,
is it really even fair to say they stopped
anything because they're donating in June
instead of in February or March or April or
May?
It's not even clear to me that there was anything
to the statement that they were stopping those
donations to these traitorous, seditious individuals.
We had this example earlier in the week specifically
about Boeing and about boycotts.
It's really hard to boycott a company like
Boeing because for the most part, Boeing is,
number one, a defense contractor, and it has
nothing to do with sort of consumer facing
decisions that we make up.
If we wanted to boycott Boeing as our airline
passengers, we would have to figure out, OK,
let's see.
I need to go from New York City to Paris.
Which airlines are flying Airbus planes or
is there some other way that I can get to
Florida without flying on a Boeing airplane?
It's really difficult to do this.
How do you even boycott Boeing?
And that's part of what makes this so pernicious.
Now, this is not the only company that is
making donations, again, to the traitorous,
treasonous Republicans, Pfizer, Intel, Ford,
Cigna, AT&T.
They've continued to donate to political action
committees that support many of these Republican
members of the House and Senate.
So to me, this is once again a calculated
public relations move.
They wanted those initial headlines to say
they are stopping the donations to people
in the House and Senate who supported Stop
the Steel and may have, you know, deliberately
or implicitly supported this January six writes,
It's not even clear it ever really even meant
anything because there are limits on political
donations.
And they waited a few months to say that they
were paused maybe of no meaning whatsoever.
And we've talked about other other examples
of this.
Last week, I had the story for you about how
many companies that are now saying we celebrate
Pride Month have donated to both candidates
and political action committees that support
candidates that are homophobic and that have
lobbied against gay marriage.
And in the, you know, the days where that
was the fight and now against so-called religious
freedom to discriminate against people who
are or are perceived to be part of the LGBT
community.
We've talked about companies who, in the wake
of the George Floyd protests around police
brutality, loudly announced we're sending
managers to implicit bias training, which
is not even clear, really has any connection
whatsoever to many of the problems that we're
dealing with as far as race goes in the United
States.
And it was an obvious and brazen PR move.
This is much the same thing.
And so am I saying boycott Boeing or don't
boycott Boeing?
No, I'm not saying anything about that.
This is not about cancelation.
This is about understand even something like
Amazon when they announced a couple of years
ago, we now pay everybody fifteen bucks an
hour.
Wow.
OK, that's great.
Well, OK, but what was the PR benefit of that
relative to the cost.
And of course it doesn't apply to third party
contractors that Amazon contracts with and
there's so many loopholes and end runs around
it.
These are mostly public relations decisions
and there is now a sort of industry based
around making these types of announcements
while behind the scenes they keep donating
to the homophobic politicians, they keep donating
to the the sedition bunch or whatever you
want to call them.
And if there is really going to be change
that we want to see, we're going to have to
demand more of these companies.
This is really not going to cut it.
And we should all be not endlessly cynical,
but healthily skeptical when we see such pronouncements
made by these corporations.
We'll have more examples of this on The David
Pakman Show Instagram.
You can follow us there at David
Pakman show.